let's bring in a familiar face Jaylen
Brown how are you doing today after that
win I'm good guys how are you good we're
excited that you are joining us you guys
put up 155 points tonight on the
offensive side how were things flowing
and how are you able to take advantage
of the Pacers the way that you guys did
well we got a great group and we just
being aggressive right now taking what
the defense has giving us and uh a lot
of shots went down for us tonight so it
was a lot of fun Jaylen Sam Mitch you
here you look at this team adding zingas
Drew holiday with you and Tatum how when
you walk out on the court and now for
the first time teams can't load up on
you they can't load up on Tatum how is
it having the freedom and the space to
get out and play the way that you want
to play and put up the numbers that you
guys are putting up because right now
you guys are off to a blistering start
yes it's great you know being able to to
to rack up wins be able to move the ball
and we doing it in like in a in an easy
fashion so um we expect to be a little
bit more adversity down the line in the
season but it's great to to start off
the season um strong and we want to keep
keep it rolling Jaylen talking to you
you sound and you acting like y'all lost
by 35 tonight man you you guys had a
great win he Focus but but in all
seriousness talk a little bit about the
relationships you guys go through this
transformation with the roster and there
are some guys on that roster last year
that you had built some longterm
relationships with talk a little little
bit about that for the fans and how
difficult at times that can
be yeah I mean it was Bitter Sweet you
know a lot of guys that are I played a
majority of my career with Marcus Smart
Rob Williams um and I know their guys
are going to have a good good seasons
over where they're at but you know a
part of what we've been building for so
long you know they help orchestrate um
so but now we got some new additions
with Drew holiday porzingis uh and we
looking to just pick up where we left
off and just try to take it to another
level well and you talk about the new
additions and it is early but when you
just look at that starting five you
could make the argument it's the best
starting five you've been a part of
Since You've Been There is is that the
sense you feel obviously we got a long
way to
go um you could say it you know uh you
could say that defensively I definitely
think it's one of the best as well um we
got a lot of Talent with this group and
we got a lot of spacing um we just got
to make sure each and every night that
we we keep the main thing the main thing
and focus on getting wins um right now
start off the season with four in a row
let's try to keep it rolling I was going
to mention that you guys do start the
season 4-0 78 games still left to play
but I know you take it one at a time
take me inside the locker room right now
we talk about the addition of Drew the
addition of porzingis how was that
chemistry felt inside the locker room
and how is that translated to the
court um right now it's been great I
think we still kind of figuring it out I
think we still can improve we're still
trying to build chemistry um we're still
trying to work some stuff out see where
guys you know like to go and uh that's
going to take a little bit of time um
and right now we're in a good spot but
as we get to playing a little bit
tougher competition some different imp
pointments you know adversity of a a
rigorous season comes in um we'll see
what we're made up then Jaylen we really
appreciate you coming on congrats on the
win congrats on 155 points as a team
we're looking forward to seeing you guys
push forward the next few months here
thank you guys smile young F y'all good
for real y'all are good for real it's
okay